hey what's up guys my name is Samuel is
I'm a property investor and I wanted to
do a Q&A where people have an
opportunity to ask me questions but I've
picked the questions that are all around
mortgages so I begin so many questions
about mortgages so this Q&A Sunday the
theme is going to be mortgages if you
like the idea of doing a themed Q&A
Sunday then let me know in the comments
below just say themes are good let me
know maybe what you want the next theme
to be if you'd prefer them to be not
themed and just random questions and
then just comment below and let me know
that you just want random questions no
theme please comment below theme no
theme comment below a mortgage is a
mortgage is a mortgage all the mortgage
means is it is a loan for you to go and
buy a house that's what a mortgage is so
the different types of mortgages all
that means is if the mortgage is got
different by different purpose so if
you're buying it if you're buying a if
you're buying a property to live in and
it's a residential mortgage if you're
buying a house to rent out it's a buy to
rent out buy to let mortgage but
hopefully that makes it real simple if
it's a HMO property then it's a HMO
mortgage because that's the specific
purpose of the loan is to buy HMR so
don't over complicate it by thinking oh
my gosh what's like on a mortgage now if
you're buying a hey chamo property
depending on the type of HMO if it's
just yeah you're just renting out three
or four rooms it's a completely normal
house it might be that a lender will
just say it's just a buy to let mortgage
but with consent to rent the rooms out
so buy to let mortgage with consent to
rent the rooms out so it really depends
how the lender will see it but my advice
is to just be completely open and honest
and transparent don't try and get a
mortgage on a property and call it
something else don't pretend you're
going to live there if you're not don't
pretend it's going to be a single there
if actually you're trying to rent it out
as a serviced accommodation unis just be
honest open on upfront
and if the lenders not happy with it
then find another lender that is so
mortgages what are we got so
sm1 says do you prefer interest only
mortgages with product fees but lower
rates or without product fees and higher
rates and do you always add the product
fee to the loan amount any help would be
much appreciated thank you for your
question so I always prefer lower fees
I'm very happy to pay a and buy fee what
this what this means is a mortgage
brokers fee and mortgage brokers fee is
usually in the hundreds of pounds and
this it's like a large purchase but you
shouldn't pay more than 1% max of the
purchase price for a broker's fee I'm
happy to pay a fee and the reason I'm
happy to pay fees because I like to get
the lowest rate the best type of lender
the least hassle and I've found in my
experience that in the long run you'll
save money by using a broker and your
save time so I don't really there's an
old saying that says watch the pennies
and the pounds will look after
themselves I actually disagree with that
statement I think that if you focus too
much on the pennies you lose the pounds
because where your focus goes that will
expand and energy flows so that's the
answer the first half the question the
second part of the question was do I add
the product fee onto the loan amount
which means that the money that I pay
the mortgage broker their fee I actually
add that onto the loan so I don't pay it
up front it just becomes part of the
part of the mortgage yes I always do
that if I can if the mortgage company
that lets me do that I'm gonna do it why
because I want to pay as little money
now and get as much cash flow as I can
I'm not what trying to be debt-free I'm
trying to be financially free so I
always do that hope that answer the
question let's see what else we've got
in regards to mortgages Harley says what
are your thoughts on over payments on
mortgages do you think that they are
beneficial in any way the answer to that
is probably not so I'd rather over pay a
mortgage than beyond repayment mortgages
people that go on we payment mortgages I
think are stupid because if you go on a
repayment mortgage all that saying is
you have no choice you have to pay back
X amount every month I'd rather be on
interest only and then just overpay if I
want then I'm not a slave I'm not
controlled what I do with with my
monthly cash flow however I don't think
I would do that why would you overpay
the mortgage instead I would rather use
that money and instead of over paying
the mortgage I would use it and save it
towards the deposit on another house
because I don't want to be debt free I
want to be financially free I don't want
to own properties outright I want to
leverage my money and the bank's money
and have as a pattern have as many as
big of a portfolio with as much cash
flow as I possibly can
so I wouldn't overpay all the mortgages
no Daniel Davis says interest only is
their property drops 30% then what okay
get this a lot so what happens if the
property drops in value you know what it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter it
doesn't affect me if I've got five
bought a house for one hundred and fifty
thousand pounds and I've borrowed a
hundred thousand pounds I'm on mortgages
one hundred grand and I'm paying four
percent interest only so I'm paying four
thousand pounds a year which is probably
going to be about what like three
hundred and sixty pounds a month but my
rent is seven hundred pound a month and
I'm in profit no matter what happens to
the purchase price or the value of the
property so no matter what happens to
that value it doesn't affect my it
doesn't affect my mortgage payments it
doesn't affect my rent
so the value of the property can go up
it can go down
you should never buy a property with the
intention to sell it unless you're doing
a flip but generally speaking if you buy
a property in the price drops it doesn't
matter if the value drops it doesn't
matter ultimately it's going to go up
over time history repeats itself and
that's how we know that so I'm not
worried about the property dropping in
value at all even if I'm in negative
equity even if my mortgage is a hundred
grand and the value of the house is 80
grand and I've got no equity at all in
that property I don't care all I care
about is that the property is making me
cash flow every single month that's it
so hope that helps so next we've got
Apple car Arnett
who says hi Samuel what about if my
credit score is low is it still possible
for a buy to let mortgage and the answer
is absolutely yes I'm not a mortgage
advisor so I can't I can't give you
bespoke mortgage advice without knowing
your situation I wouldn't be qualified
to do that anyway but okay let me tell
you this you're the lenders the banks
they don't care that much about you when
it comes to you buying buy-to-let
properties they care more about the
buy-to-let properties because when
you're buying a house to live in
it's your home they care about you
because the home is a liability meaning
it doesn't give you any income it loses
money so when you're buying a home the
bank's want to know can you afford to
live in this home so they'll ask you
questions like how much do you earn
let's see your credit and they'll want
to see it's really good don't want to
see you condone your affordability
checks on you and on the home but when
you're buying a property investment to
rent out they're not that interested in
you or whatever so that's why people
that have got zero income no income
people that have got county court
judgments against their name bad credit
the banks are still lending the money
not it's not just a guaranteed but in
many instances there's still any money
why because they'll say let's have a
look at the house that you want to have
money
for the house is good the house is going
to pay the bank not you does that make
sense
so we're vital air it's less important
about you it's more important about
about the house when you bought when
you're borrowing bridging finance
especially they do not care about you
they don't care about your credit I
don't care about your background they
care about the house which is why it's
important to be able to find good houses
the first thing you need to be able to
do as a property investor is finding
good houses you find good houses there
will be good finance for you believe me
I mean geez I'll find that's the deal if
it's a good enough house so that's
really important if you've been told no
by your bank and for every single
question about mortgage advice I can
give you I can give you my experience
but the are usually always then with go
and speak to a good broker because you
always want to have a good broker if
your bank tells you no I've had
situations where 72 year old ladies are
trying to come in on my crash course and
then I try and do deals and their bank
is telling them no way we can't lend to
you and then they write themselves off
that I can't get a mortgage but then
what happens is they go and speak to a
good broker my broker anyone that does
any advanced training with me will get
access to my pal to him and everything
everything by the way you speak to a
good broker suddenly they'll bet they
have access to all the banks and they'll
find a broker that fits you bespoke so
hopefully that helps let's see what else
we got on the on the subject of
mortgages maybe one or two more okay SSH
and rub says if you do the RR strategy I
would assume you mean the RR ah strategy
is by refurb refinance rent since when
you add value to house and be financed
it would you get away with buying and
buying with a buy to let mortgage and
then refinancing once as banks don't
like it
I know bridging loans is the usual way
of doing this okay if you're buying a
house with the whole intention of adding
value to it and then refinancing it when
you first get the house you don't want
to get a normal body to let mortgage on
the house and then
because normally when you get buy to let
mortgage there are fees involved but
also you'll have usually like a minimum
of maybe two year fixed and there's no
point getting a buy to let mortgage just
to then in a few months time get another
by to that mortgage because you're just
going to get you just gonna have to pay
a lot more money you're gonna get fines
and all kinds of stuff that penalty
fines so the simplest way to do it is to
buy the property cash add value cash and
then we find out and then pull all your
money back out and then with that cash
do it again and do it again and do it
again and keep doing it until you wonder
how many houses you possibly can before
the rules change or whatever now if you
haven't got the cash that's when you're
gonna need to get a bridging finance or
use other people's money or get a
joint-venture so yeah don't use a
buy-to-let for that first instance hope
that helps
so guys that's about all we got time for
today on the mortgage Q&A next week
we're going to do another Q&A so if
you've got questions about property
comment them below I'll do my best to
answer as many as I can also don't
forget to let me know do you think we
should do themed or non themed comment
below as well I want to see as many
comments below themed or non themed the
more comments you type below as well it
always helps the YouTube algorithm which
means that we'll get more views which
then incentivize me to make more content
so comment below if you enjoyed the
video please don't forget to smash that
like button and if you're not subscribed
to this channel please subscribe I love
you forever I'll see you next week thank
you
[Music]